if you don't hear me you can't have your
edible passwords PayPal's head of global
development jonathan leblanc has
released a presentation on the future of
passwords and it has nothing to do with
a combination of numbers and special
characters instead leblanc wants to put
a chip into your brain or embedded
device in your belly that's powered by
your own stomach acid this so-called
natural body identification would
replace numerical pass code instead
tagging privileged users with their
biometric code AK a heartbeat glucose
levels and other specific settings in
our own bodies all right so you guys
know that i love these stories about
future stuff in technology and how it's
affecting our brains and our bodies
we're just going to become robots right
like trees on robot here but are we just
were swallowing pills what could
possibly go wrong with that has anybody
ever seen 2001 yeah what could possibly
go wrong with this yeah the lights are
on yes we amazed well my password is
gonna be Kafka yeah or or well I thought
or well I'm just gonna swallow or well
and let it go through yeah what do you
think about this passwords how do you
manage your passwords right okay well
I'm running out of us like security
questions number one like I'm running
online now making [ __ ] up yeah totally
running out but I saw you swallow the
pill as the password natural password ID
in it I think what would be worse than
forgetting your password is pooping out
your password i mean like how does that
even work does it say saying about our
society like we love your password is
diarrhea what does it say about us that
we love pills so much every commercial
right is for a pill and then there's an
hour of what told you that we would want
to go this way if they could done if
they could they just sneak up behind you
and lights and on the subway i just
energen ever you tell you about and
that's coming to this is this is just
gonna get ugly yeah so if we're gonna do
this I wouldn't if you're running out of
security question
would do that but I also read that now
they are having tattoos that can do the
same thing with the password so that
would be the only reason to ever get a
tribal tattoo I got soil and the reason
finally later well then they're just
gonna hack your arm off right right
korobi like Minority Report you know and
everything goes through your eye and
then one day they'll just come around
and rip your eye out or a hooker just
get a sort of barcode tattoo you gotta
just scan and he just goes right you are
coded yeah I do what exactly yeah um is
cyber war scarier than real war like to
me this all leads us every time we do a
robot story if you say to me there's
always lead to Tuesday always wash topic
oies it's always disturbing always leads
to I don't know what that says about me
a lot of pot inside I don't know well
like it always leads to Terminator and
Skynet and well you know you know they
just it's just more opportunity for
control and and I am so suspicious yes
of that that that I want no part of it
but you know I can't get around but you
can't fight it what are you gonna do
everyone's gonna be swallowing pills and
you're gonna have no pass all my
passwords are now smokie there was a
pass for everything yeah anyway what do
you think swallowed passwords crazy
would you do it let us know in the
comments right
you